des élections quelles élections pour
près de la moitié des mères au québec
les dernières élections n'ont été qu'une
simple formalité
en 2017
48,8 % des maires ont été élus par
acclamation
dans une municipalité québécoise sur
cinq c'est l'ensemble du conseil qui est
élu avant même le jour du vote
la palme des élections sans opposition
revenir la ville de sainte julie au sud
de montréal
de 2005 à 2007 toucherait de 70% des
sièges ont été attribués par acclamation
[Musique]
il
saleh laurentides se vante d'être une
ville en pleine campagne avec près de
25000 habitants c'est la principale
municipalités de la mrc de montcalm dans
lanaudière
le maire patrick massé il a été élu sans
opposition en 2017
le nouveau projet c'est dans notre
vision d'une ville en pleine expansion
alors que saint lin se développe à un
rythme effréné monsieur massé a décidé
de ne pas se représenter aux élections
il quitte au moment où la ville fait
face à un sérieux problème à certains
moments il manque carrément dos un enjeu
fondamental à l' approche des élections
municipales
[Musique]
st gelais est devenue une destination de
choix pour plusieurs jeunes familles
[Musique]
c'est convivial pour les enfants pauvres
c'était déjà une femme est partout donc
l'école et à une minutes en auto
[Musique]
avec quatre jeunes enfants ça bouge
toujours dans la toute nouvelle maison
de bianca bourda déveiner marciano
ils ont acheté leur maison il ya deux
ans et depuis leur quartier s'est
métamorphosé
[Musique]
en 2019 et 2020 saint lin a permis la
construction de 814 nouvelle maison
durant la même période il y en a eu que
285 à joliette joliette compte pourtant
deux fois plus d'habitants un hôpital un
cégep et un palais de justice
même pas le temps de paver les rues que
déjà un nouveau quartier voit le jour
tout va très vite peut-être trop vite
[Musique]
pour bien qu'à est venue la fin de
l'après midi est toujours une course
contre la montre
leur objectif schouppe et nettoyer la
vaisselle donner le bain à quatre
enfants tout ça avant 17h30
c'est bien qu'un et venez doivent tout
faire très vite c'est qu'à chaque jour
autour de 17h30 les problèmes commencent
toujours
aujourd'hui pardo 25 ans et demi plus
tard
[Musique]
bien qu a presque réussi à tout faire
dans l'état les deux jumeaux sont profs
sans perdre une minute qui c'est au tour
des deux plus grandes d'entrer dans la
baignoire
malheureusement il est déjà trop tard
[Musique]
une forme de supplice de la goutte sur
la rue de bianca dans tout le secteur
autour de chez elle des résidences
plaints du même problème l'aqueduc
asselin ne suffirait aux heures de
pointe il n'y a pas assez de pression
[Musique]
habituelle réveillé par une gauche c'est
comme lorsque j'étais enfant ma douche
ce que je veux
franck gauche il alors que le même pu
tuer comme ça la règle trou de 3
secondes sans la fin on se prépare en
tout cas pas moi je me sens pas laver
les cheveux une fois pendant cinq jours
mon fils était avec les crèmes solaires
aquitaine c'était vraiment déplaisant
960t j'ai senti que ma qualité de vie a
pris un coup le pic est au bout de ces
cinq jours là que j'ai appris la ville
il ya d'autres solutions concrètes
qu'elle imprime au frais apparaissent se
sentir mal pour moi elle m'a proposé de
donner aux enfants un petit homme le
matin
[Musique]
nous avons demandé des explications au
maire car en plus d'être maire monsieur
massé est aussi le préfet de la mrc de
montcalm il y est responsable du dossier
de l'aménagement de plus il est
président de la commission permanente
sur les enjeux urbains à la fédération
des municipalités du québec mais patrick
massé a refusé une demande d'entrevue
disant qu'il ne se représente pas à la
mairie de saint lin dans un message sur
facebook le maire massé a néanmoins
donné son point de vue sur les problèmes
d'eau potable de sa ville
bonjour à tous je cherche un noir de
chez nous au cours des derniers mois la
ville a reçu des questions et des comas
pas par rapport à l'interdiction
d'arrosage et sur les 60 général de
notre approvisionnement en eau potable à
saint-lin l'eau de l'aqueduc vient de la
nappe phréatique
au lieu de prendre l'eau de la rivière
l'eau est pompée du sol selon le maire
pour alimenter tous les nouveaux
développements
la ville doit trouver de nouvelles
sources d'eau il faut creuser de
nouveaux puits et les ajouter aux six
puits déjà en opération
chacun des lieux puis a à lui seul la
capacité de former à la demande actuelle
et aux besoins de
la ville promet de régler le problème
pas que duke avec de nouveaux puits et
d'importants investissements de québec
et d'ottawa mais à saint lin ce n'est
pas tout le monde qui est branché sur le
réseau municipal plusieurs résidants ont
dit puis privé et eux se demandent si la
ville n'est pas en train de régler le
problème d'aqueduc en leur siphonnant
lot de sous les pieds
j'ai vu la date des soldes au fil des
ans s'est tranquillement mais tout un
petit peu à la baisse une tendance à la
baisse
pascal leblanc habite saint lin mais sa
maison n'est pas branché à l'aqueduc de
la ville dans son quartier situé au sud
les résidents ont dépuis brive et qui
doivent entretenir à leurs frais moi ce
sont mon terrain on était à l'honneur un
puits nettoyer c'est dans le plus pur de
résidence est fait comme ça
d'un convive 50.4 monsieur leblanc
détient une formation technique dans le
traitement des eaux la gestion de l'eau
c'est son métier
au cours de l'été 2020 certains voisins
se retrouvent avec des puits
complètement à sec la personne qui me
disant j'ai pu d'eau dans mon puis j'ai
plus d'eau dans mon puits avec le plus
aussi pascal leblanc se demande alors si
la baisse du niveau d'eau ne serait pas
dû à tous ces nouveaux développements
que la ville de saint lin a autorisé
parce que la nappe souterraine dans
sousse et se relaxer comme un verre
d'eau puis à chaque fois qu'on va
implanter un nouveau puits mais ça ne
paye quand vous mettre dans le bol d'eau
d'alevins
les réponses de la ville arrivent au
compte gouttes
pascal leblanc se tournent donc vers le
ministère de l'environnement le
gouvernement provincial limite
l'utilisation de l'eau souterraine afin
de protéger la nappe phréatique entre
2015 et 2020 saint lin a pompé plus
d'eau que les limites permises le
ministère de l'environnement assure
suivre la situation de très près surtout
qu'à saint lin les besoins en eau
potable ne font qu'augmenter
[Musique]
il ya une immense mons tours de condos
qui a été construite qui je pense que ça
va être habité bien tous les gens avec
un booster terrasse
piscine
puis le ça m'inquiète un peu
c'est tours de condos va être habité je
n'aime pas trop le tube est parti il
déjà très bien même petit optimale ce
qui peut bien maintenant je veux même
pas une machine ça va être quoi quand la
tour est habité le promoteur de
l'immeuble assure avoir prévu le coup en
attendant de régler le problème d'eau
seuls les deux premiers étages seront
occupés en plus la tour dispose de son
propre réservoir d'eau salée ou s'ils
comptent sur des réservoirs souterrains
sauf que pour y maintenir le niveau la
municipalité doit acheter de l'eau
livrées par camion citerne
depuis 2018 saleh a payé plus de deux
cent soixante deux mille dollars pour
acheter de l'eau à l'extérieur dans son
message aux citoyens le maire soutient
que les problèmes d'eau sont
essentiellement causée par les
conditions climatiques
vous avez sûrement pu constater que la
région n'a pas reçu les quantités de
pluie et de neige actuelles au cours des
deux dernières années pour la recharge
de l'année en fait le marc massé ne fait
jamais de lien entre les problèmes d'eau
et toutes les nouvelles constructions
pourtant des groupes comme équiterre et
greenpeace ont vivement critiqué le
développement de la municipalité
les écologistes ont même mis la mrc de
montcalm sur leur liste des films
d'horreur de l'aménagement du territoire
québécois en qualifiant de massacre
l'étalement urbain dans la région
[Musique]
l'étalement urbain dans le sud du québec
se fait principalement au détriment des
milieux naturels
70% du développement se fait en milieu
boisé et 10% en milieu humide dans tout
le canada ce sont les principaux centres
urbains du québec qui ont connu la plus
forte expansion avec la pression
immobilière actuelle plus du tiers des
milieux naturels du grand montréal
pourraient disparaître d'ici 2050
[Applaudissements]
la perte des espaces verts voteraient
235 millions de dollars par année juste
dans le grand montréal
pour arriver à ce montant des chercheurs
ont donné une valeur monétaire aux
différents services qu'offre la nature
des services comme la production de
nourriture la pollinisation la
séquestration du carbone ou le
traitement naturel de l'eau selon leurs
calculs perdre un hectare de forêt coûte
près de 4000 $ par année en ajoutant les
terres agricoles et les milieux humides
ils obtiennent une facture de 235
millions de dollars par année
[Musique]
sujet de la rivière et son conjoint
habite depuis deux ans dans un des vieux
secteur de saint lin laurentides
c'était pour eux l'endroit idéal pour la
retraite
mais c'est chez nous
on est bien on ou de l'aele on est grand
j'ai pas de voisins collé sous louer un
an et demi après leur arrivée le rêve
d'une retraite paisible en campagne
tourne au cauchemar
ben ça commence tranquillement ça a
commencé que ma voisine m'a appelé parce
qu'on y sur un puits mitoyenne m appelle
un lundi matin blême dit elle on a un
problème à john d'opodo avec le lait
punique mme aubry madame la rivière à
manquer d'eau pendant ces semaines nous
a duré un mois et demi avant que 1 le
foreur soient disponibles parce que les
fora ils sont tous très occupés tout le
monde en même temps marqué tôt
[Musique]
ce qu'on s'est servi de l'épicier pour
les toilettes 14 pour les besoins
naturels oc salve d'épisodes
on se salue aussi de les piscines pour
garder de l'eau chaude en permanence au
coup on a besoin thérapeutique
tecolam a amputé son copain l'a bien
puis lucho bien chaud qui tu dis on va
vendre l'amour cesse de maison comment
peux tu vends d'une maison topo doute
[Musique]
trouvé une nouvelle source d'eau sur son
terrain a été complexe les ouvriers ont
dû creuser à trois reprises chez madame
la rivière une facture de plusieurs
milliers de dollars
tu deviens prochain coup deux mois
l'éclipsé mais qui va avoir les clefs
des maisons
la ville a embauché un hydrogéologue
pour analyser l'état de la nappe
phréatique il analysé l'impact des tests
de pompage qui visait à accroître la
pression d'eau dans la queue du cac
l'expert conclut qu'il est peu probable
que les tests et provoqué l'assèchement
des puits privés comme celui de madame
la rivière l'hydrogéologue payés par la
ville constate que la qualité de l'eau
prélevée dans le secteur est médiocre
mais que le niveau d'eau de la nappe
phréatique demeure stable si le niveau
d'eau est bon pascal leblanc souligne
que la ville interdit tout de même
l'arrosage l'été sous peine d'amendé
strauss kahn même un peu curieux de nos
voisins
vont fuser des centaines de gallons menu
tout ça le repos d'impact plusieurs
citoyens se sont tournés vers le
ministère l'environnement qui a reçu une
quarantaine de plaintes la plupart de
résidents inquiets qu'ils ont payé cher
leur manque d'eau et qui veulent savoir
si la ville peut être tenu responsable
mais c'est tout un combat de démontrer
que l'absence d'eau privés chez moi
découlent d'un développement effréné da
par la municipalité où on m'a volé mon
nous essentiellement maître marc andré
lechasseur est spécialisé en urbanisme
et en droit municipal
difficile à faire comme démonstration
mais passer si cette preuve le est faite
que le mono ont été prises par la
municipalité pour permettre à d'autres
d'en avoir
le certainement quelque chose qui va se
passer à ce moment là le ministère de
l'environnement a déjà servi un avis de
non-conformité à la municipalité de
saint lin pour avoir sur utiliser la
nappe phréatique
le ministère assure suivre de près ce
dossier
c'est la première étape d'un processus
qui vont enclencher un remède
vraisemblablement pour qu' on ne
compromettent pas la ressource en eau
pour les générations futures
[Musique]
pascal leblanc s'est porté volontaire
pour tester le niveau de pression chez
bianca bourde à quand la pression d'eau
dans l'aqueduc est trop faible la
qualité de l'eau peut vraiment devenir
problématique parce que c'est bon
c'est peu le ministère de
l'environnement recommande de maintenir
idéalement la pression d'eau entre 60 et
80 livres à bord du
vide et mission prévention doivent avoir
plus quatre ans pour quelque chose
d'intéressant résidence en bas de 20
livres la pression n'est pas assez forte
des substances nocives peuvent
s'infiltrer dans le réseau c'est
pourquoi les municipalités vont alors
émettre un avis d'ébullition
pour les poulets sa guise un samedi
c'est pas une bonne pression là dans un
réseau mais pour les bornes fontaines
c'est pas évident non plus pour les
pompiers
pour l'instant les pompiers n'utilise
pas les bornes fontaines parce que la
pression y est insuffisante mais le chef
du service des incendies explique qu'il
dispose de camions citernes et qui peut
répondre adéquatement aux urgences
avant de quitter ses fonctions le maire
massé a admis qu'il fallait trouver les
solutions
j'emmène avancée dans le processus pour
creuser de nouveaux puits qui
s'ajouteront aux 16 puis que nous avons
déjà sauf que le ministère de
l'environnement n'a toujours pas donné
le feu vert aux deux nouveaux puits
promis par le maire pour l'instant la
solution du maire massé passe par encore
plus de nouveaux secteurs à développer
développement de nouveaux projets
résidentiels sur un pourcentage minime
du territoire est donc essentiel dans la
réalisation de notre projet de
modernisation de notre réseau de plus
qui l'emmènera des revenus
supplémentaires pour la vie avec le
marquis quitte la direction de la ville
les futurs élus auront toutes une tâche
à accomplir
la gestion de l'eau à saint lin sera le
grand défi de la nouvelle administration
[Musique]
le modèle de la banlieue coûte beaucoup
plus cher en service public la gestion
de l'eau des déchets du transport ou des
services d'urgence coûtant fonds publics
environ 1400 16 $ par ménage en milieu
urbain contre
3472 dollar en moyenne par famille de
banlieue
le gouvernement du québec a lancé un
vaste chantier afin de moderniser les
règles encadrant l'aménagement du
territoire la loi actuelle a été adopté
il ya plus de 40 ans
les femmes représentent moins du tiers
des élus dans le monde municipal en 2010
est seulement 18,9 pour cent des
municipalités québécoises ont choisi une
mairesse ce qui est une amélioration par
rapport à 2005 seule 3,9 pour cent des
conseils municipaux sont majoritairement
composés de fable
eastman c'est les montagnes 4 lac
paisible dont le lac d'argent au pied du
mont orford ceux et celles qui habitent
le village à l'année ils sont
profondément attachés que je trouvais
des fautes de la liberté on est
les seuls grands maisons sont
originaires dix semaines pour elle la
protection de l'environnement est
l'enjeu principal des prochaines
élections et ici le débat sur
l'environnement est directement liée au
développement immobilier
mais on peux tu parler aussi de la crise
climatique
elle est réelle
puis on n'a plus beaucoup de temps
de s'attaquer à un problème si un coin
d'aménagement local d'aménagement je
pense que c'était un bon point où
commencer il n'aura un nouveau maire de
7 novembre prochain ils vont la ramie
qui était en poste depuis 2013 a
subitement démissionné en juillet
évoquant des raisons santé
comme les gaulois chaque année pour le
poisson pas frais mais je voudrais que
la dernière année avec le club entre
autres est très difficile la pression
des élections à une peau non plus ça que
la dernière année la troupe moins facile
pour annie fortin le goût de la
politique ne date pas d'hier son père a
été conseillé son grand père a été maire
dix semaines elle est une des deux
femmes qui brigue aujourd'hui la mairie
du village
elle avoue que son premier mandat à
titre de conseillère a été des plus
mouvementées
parce que c'était moi même j'ai pensé
démissionner tellement que c'était un
patrick mais que d'un autre qui est
conseillé depuis 2009 estime que
certains citoyens ont dépassé les
limites de se dette toujours soumis à
des critiques qui parfois sont fondées
mais parfois son corps et maryvonne 80
de notre intégrité
ça affecte tout le monde ça tellement
affecté notre mère comme un bébé
il a remis sa démission
les dernières années ont été marquées
par de nombreuses querelles toujours
autour du même sujet la construction de
nouveaux projets de quartiers
résidentiels
bailly semaines actuellement
si on parle développement c'est ce que
de l'extérieur c'est super mais ça se
développe
c'est comme des champignons ne poussent
pas que tout le clos des hôtels est un
ardent défenseur du mont orford il se
présente pour devenir conseiller parce
qu'il estime que la ville d'eastman est
trop conciliante avec les promoteurs qui
souhaitent développer la montagne en dix
points c'est un des ponts c'est la
construction du barrage de maintien je
pense pas qu'elle aille personnes au
conseil municipal qu'il soit des
enveloppes pour faire procéder à fait
mais ça devient plus facile de s'imposer
des affaires qui possède peut-être
position on était plus proche d'une
vraie mentalité de protection de
l'environnement ce cas tu nous dises que
ces offres ont fait la partie belle aux
promoteurs s'étendant sur six pauvresse
puis ça fait partie de la lourdeur qui
nous qui nous est mise répétitivement
sur des épaules les frictions entre
monsieur des hôtels et certains membres
du conseil ne date pas d'hier claude et
hôtels a déjà siégé au conseil
consultatif en environnement dix
semaines le cce est chargée de
conseiller les innus sur les dossiers
environnementaux
alors qu'il était membre du conseil
monsieur des hôtels découvre un
règlement datant de 2012 un règlement
toujours en vigueur dans lequel la
municipalité s'engage à protéger et
conserver à l'état naturel plus de 40%
des terres du mont orford
soleil malin n'a jamais été appliquée
monsieur des hôtels et les autres
membres du cce conclu qu'il faudrait un
moratoire sur toute construction dans
certaines zones de la montagne quand
l'eau des hôtels demande lors d'une
assemblée publique si les élus ont
l'intention d'appliquer ou non le
moratoire il est sanctionné
neuf points destitution au sein du
comité consultatif en environnement le
cce je propose de distribuer selon des
hôtels
pour nous c'est un violation de du
caractère confidentiel a pas la main des
discussions du ccg avaient pas droit dit
son public mais le lanceur d alerte
météo mais monsieur des hôtels est
sortie des journaux pour vilipender la
municipalité puis le conseil s'est pas
assuré d'avoir le concours soit au moins
au courant avant d'aller nous accuser
publiquement que terrain n'a à ce jour
été désigné comme aire protégée mais
selon le conseiller mecs dans l'aude la
réglementation actuelle protège de facto
plus de la moitié de la montagne la
réglementation fonctionne dans bien des
cas
c'est pas là pour faire plaisir aux
promoteurs de fait qu'on ajoute des
contraintes tout le temps parce qu'on
veut le protéger l'environnement vu du
ciel les montagnes de la région semblent
encore préservé leur état naturel
mais depuis quelques années un réseau
août il s'étend au pied de la montagne
pavant la voie à des développements
résidentiels très prisé par les citadins
en quête des espaces verts
le premier un conte première endroit
qu'on veut investir a dit fortin a
accepté de nous guider vers quelques
nouveaux projets résidentiels à eastman
ce qui dérange le plus
même à
ça qu'on s'installe
service
un nouveau chemin atteint le sommet du
mont liban hauteur juste à côté du mot
fuck et en
privé
pendant plusieurs jours les résidents se
sont plaints du dynamitage autorisée par
la municipalité
a dit fortin souligne un autre problème
à un carrefour la pente est très abrupt
et voyez les camions de pompier de
service et s'il va falloir avec son
truck lindon ou conseil a dit fortin
s'est dit inquiète elle craint que les
pompiers ne soit pas en mesure de monter
la côte avec le camion en cas d incendie
ils ont ils nous ont répondu qu' il va
pouvoir monter mais ce ne sera pas
facile bien une valve et post
mais ce que ça va prendre un camion
spécial oui
va falloir acheter un camion qu'on a
fait l'appel d'offres cauet et quatre
roues motrices ont s'adapter à ces
nouveaux chemins l'eau le bois est
devenu non c'est pas donné
ça coûte combien fin
si vous avez le droit d'élever
ses 500 milles
un peu plus loin un projet prévoit une
centaine de maisons tout juste au pied
du mont orford la route emprunte le
tracé d'un ancien chemin forestier
elle m'inquiète pas
malgré la présence de milieux humides la
municipalité a reconnu un droit acquis
ce qui a permis au propriétaire du
terrain de transformer le vieux sentiers
forestiers en route assez large pour y
permettre la circulation automobile
c'est la première fois que madame fortin
voit le résultat
même montagne
patrick mc donough de soutien que
légalement la municipalité ne pouvait
faire autrement que de reconnaître le
droit acquis du propriétaire du terrain
le chemin principal sur lequel le
développement se trouvent et ont pu
faire la démonstration qu'ils s'agissait
bel et bien d'un droit acquis ces
vérifications ont été faites auprès de
nos aviseurs légaux qui ont confirmé que
à leur avis il s'agissait bel et bien
droit zaki l'un des propriétaires du
terrain est aussi un entrepreneur qui
fournit des services à la municipalité
un entrepreneur acquis yvon laramée
l'ancien maire a déjà prêté de l'argent
devant la commission municipale du
québec yvon laramée a reconnu s'être
placé en conflit d'intérêts
la cmq lui a imposé une suspension de 20
jours pour avoir contrevenu au code
d'éthique et déontologiques des élus de
la municipalité d'eastman alors que
l'avenir de la montagne attise déjà les
tensions la suspension du maire vient
souffler sur les braises l'éthique du
maire devient alors un sujet d' enquête
dans les médias locaux notamment en
raison de terre et que l'ex maire
possède au bout du chemin khartoum
[Musique]
à la base
le vieux chemin colonial a été ouvert à
la circulation il ya une dizaine
d'années pour permettre le passage des
camions dakar hier l'administration du
maire laramée a procédé à la réfection
du chemin en 2016 et en 2017 en
permettant d'y ajouter l'électricité les
travaux ont ouvert la voie à de nouveaux
développements résidentiels
[Musique]
entre temps le terrain du maire qui
était enclavé au moment de l'achat est
aujourd'hui desservis par une rue
[Musique]
certainement comprendre la valeur
par définition ça vient de faire
décuplez peut-être la valeur aux
intérêts parce que c'est la chose
indispensable à l'obtention d'un permis
de construction ce terrain que
l'ex-maire à payer 75 mille dollars en
2004 vaut près de 400 mille dollars
selon la dernière évaluation municipale
quand une rue devant chez vous de toutes
les options possibles qui souffrent et
ce moment-là pas la mesure de ce que le
règlement autorise à faire alors c'est
la clé de voûte en faire
nous avons rencontré yvon laramée mais à
sa demande 100 caméras il rappelle que
c'est le tribunal qui a forcé la ville à
ouvrir le chemin khartoum pour permettre
le passage des camions ils vont la ram
et ajoute que la municipalité a fait des
travaux sur le chemin essentiellement
pour mieux protéger les milieux humides
qui longe la route
tout ce débat entourant le développement
des semaines a poussé agnès grandmaison
a posé sa candidature pour un poste de
conseillère on n'est pas contre le
développement mais est-ce qu'on peut
justement repenser à sa puis le faire de
façon plus intelligente que le
développement soit fait de façon
intelligente puisque ça ait pas lieu
dans l'est dans les milieux humides par
exemple pour heidi fortin les projets
résidentiels défendues par l'ancien
maire ont divisé la population d'eastman
mois source d'un échec total si la
population est déchiré qu'on n'a pas
réussi à trouver un terrain d'entente ou
juste d'avoir une oreille parce que dans
le fond
ils écoutent s'attendre avec deux femmes
candidates eastman est assuré d'avoir
une nouvelle mairesse le 7 novembre et
devra réconcilier la volonté des
électeurs qui souhaitent protéger
l'environnement et la pression de
citadins qui veulent s'installer dans la
région
le salaire des élus varie énormément
d'une municipalité à l'autre dans un
petit village de 2000 habitants comme
eastman le maire laramée cumulé des
revenus de 41 1391 dollars par année aso
les laurentides où résident 20
3299 personnes le maire touche près de
164 1000 dollars patrick massé est l'un
des maires les mieux payés au québec
monsieur masse et gagne soixante-trois
mille dollars de plus que le maire de
saint jean sur richelieu une ville
pourtant quatre fois plus populeuse
le maire allait la plante reçoit 100
mille trois cent soixante dollars
l'hôtel de ville de saint jean sur
richelieu a été le théâtre de nombreuses
altercations vous assisterez ce soir à
ce qu'il ya de plus sale dans polisse et
vous observerez
de la pure partisanerie basé sur des
fausses allégations
actuellement la ville de saint jean sous
l'influencé d'un putsch partisans visa
définitivement à nuire à mon travail à
me déstabiliser et à affaiblir je pense
qu'il faut arrêter ce qu'on support est
une seule mais là je pense que vous
allez un peu loin la commission
municipale du québec a qualifié les
conflits entre élus de guerre de pouvoir
de guérilla politique entre deux camps
je lâcherai pas le morceau d'un côté il
y a le maire la plante élu pour la
première fois en 2010 est l'autre clan
est formée de neuf conseillers à saint
jean on les surnomme le gros des 9 rue
le groupe des 9 détient la majorité au
conseil
ils gagnent chaque vote
nous attendent et
le vin il y a les citoyens de plus en
plus exaspérée jusqu'à favorise entre
vous ont jusqu à pékin on aura plus
d'argent voyez-vous sa
vocation des chicanes entre élus qui ont
coûté jusqu'à maintenant un million cinq
cent mille dollars en frais d'avocats
pour défendre ses idées le maire de
saint jean n'a pas peur de la
confrontation on ne détruira pas
l'environnement ou en faveur d'un climat
heureux à l'hôtel de ville monsieur
laplante a réussi à mobiliser une partie
de la population en promettant le
protéger les terrains de golf contre
tout développement résidentiel les
terrains de golf sauzeau nichols lusage
qui permit sur ses terres et l'os et
récréatifs et la municipalité est comme
moi là moi je dois à rien a aucun
promoteur et aucun commentaire de golf
intérieur c'est plus qu'autre chose
d'une source de pollution de son côté le
groupe 9 est favorable à l'idée de
transformer au moins un des parcours en
nouveaux quartiers résidentiels jamais
d'affairé de compromis sur l'intérêt des
citoyens aux en faveur d'intérêts
partisans du groupe des 9
[Musique]
monsieur laplante est arrivé avec que
des côtes cia sommet discorde dans tout
et il est actuellement le seul à voir l
eau nous retrouve narcissique là ça fait
penser à notre place à non pas la garde
quand quelqu'un comtesse les médias en
disant que ces défis et aux attaques les
médias sont conclues diatta conseil et
quand lui indiqué que l'administration
conclu que les mains sales contre lui
que la chance commerce et développement
économique et compte lui même les
simples gens atteints comme si c'est un
porte voix qui m'arrivait washington
plusieurs conflits entre le maire la
plante et le groupe des neuf ont dû se
régler devant les tribunaux par exemple
dès le début de son mandat le maire
laplante a été poursuivi par un
promoteur immobilier qui lui reprochait
des propos tenus durant la campagne
électorale le conseil municipal a refusé
de payer la défense du maire
mais je dis débourser 45 dollars contre
la ville pour l'obliger à payer mes
frais d'avocat ta peau et lui promet de
la ville de lhassa les gens pour qu on a
répété ses frais d'avocats pour une
connerie qui a fait avant d'être juste
le tribunal a finalement donné raison au
maire la plante
la juge
vient écrire que lie la ville aurait dû
voir le stratagème du promoteur tels que
dénoncée par la mer la plage
la véritable guérilla politique éclate
cependant avec la sphère du chef de
cabinet le conseil contrôlé dans le
groupe des 9 a congédié guy grenier le
chef de cabinet et proche collaborateur
d'alain la plante son chef de cabinet je
porte on a parlé parce que c'est devant
le tribunal mais son chef de cabinet me
l'a congédié ou c'était parti de lui
parce qu'on trouvait que c'était
processus de travail et sont venus
congédié sans aucune raison mon propre
chef de cabinet dans le fond tout ça
c'était une façon de matin deux mois
matin deux mois à tout moment pour venir
m'empêcher d'exercer mon mon rôle mais
mes responsabilités a titré demain
pendant plusieurs semaines la sphère du
chef de cabinet monopolise l'hôtel de
ville de saint jean à plusieurs reprises
le groupe des neuf votes le congédiement
du chef de cabinet à chaque fois le
maire le ré embauche en utilisant les
pouvoirs de l'exécutif
le groupe des 9 met fin à ce jeu de ping
pong en retirant tous les pouvoirs du
comité exécutif quand ça dure et trois
assemblées constitueront le poids au
conseil le maire se dit victime d'
attaques anti démocratique la ville de
saint-jean-sur-richelieu vit
présentement ce qu'on peut qualifier de
coup d'état politique
dans la sphère du chef de cabinet la
commission municipale du québec a jugé
que le maire laplante avait pris le
parti de son ami guy grenier contre les
intérêts de la ville il a suspendu
pendant quatre-vingt quinze jours qui
détermine l'intérêt de la ville donc
lorsque moi je viens défendre un employé
de ce que je viens défendre dans le fond
mon rôle ma responsabilité en tant que
maire est-ce que je travaille dans
l'intérêt
de la ville ou non je suis pas du même
avis de mes opposants politiques
pour ce qui est de la validité du
congédiement du chef de cabinet elle
sera déterminée par le tribunal
la cour devra aussi se pencher sur un
autre dossier la ville poursuit un
groupe de citoyens pour harcèlement
quand tu es rendu sur les médias sociaux
que lui porte atteinte à l'intégrité
physique ou morale de quelqu'un quand
quelqu'un se sent menacé mais je pense
qu'il faut arrêter ça la ville de
saint-jean accuse un petit groupe de
citoyens d'avoir harcelé et intimidé les
élus du groupe des 9 ce qui est étonnant
dans cette affaire c'est que la ville
reproche à son propre mère d'avoir
orchestré cette campagne de salissage
dans les documents de cour les avocats
de la ville plaide calais laplante a
misé sur un groupe de partisans
indéfectibles dans le but de discréditer
ses adversaires en vue des prochaines
élections encore la fin des punks
poursuivre système de soins c'est
d'abord et avant tout pour ceux qui me
disent ils le mois de plus trois
employés de la ville accuse le maire
d'harcèlement une autre affaire qui sera
entendu par le tribunal administratif du
travail le maire l'appelant dit qu'il
n'a rien à cacher et qu'en misant sur sa
transparence il va remporter les
prochaines élections je bénéficie d'un
appui immense de la population j'ai
aussi une équipe extraordinaire derrière
moi et puis
comme je vous disais mon cal va
[Musique]
jusqu'à aujourd'hui la ville de saint
jean à débourser 1 million 500 mille
dollars pour payer les frais juridiques
des différents conflits entre élus le
maire dit que toutes ces dépenses c'est
la faute du groupe des 9 yvan berthelot
réplique que c'est le maire le grand
responsable chose certaine ce sont tous
les citoyens qui vont payer la facture
[Musique]